PHILIP TAN: My
name is Philip Tan.
I'm a research scientist
here at the MIT Game Lab,
and I've been teaching
various game courses here
at MIT for about 10 years.
Every night I play StarCraft
for a couple of games,
just to help me calm
down and get to sleep.
So that's kind of
my regular ritual.
Otherwise, lately,
I've picked up
this game called Desert
Golfing, which is just
kind of endless
golfing on the iPhone,
which is strangely soothing,
yet maddening at the same time.
Right now I'm actually working
with Blizzard Entertainment
to try to create different ways
for players-- for people who
are interested in StarCraft--
to spectate a game being played
by professionals.
So we're about fixing.
I'm really looking forward
to what the students end up
making.
They usually impress
me with some sort
of far-out-of-left-field
approach to the problems that
we put forward to them.
And this year we are ramping
up the design challenge,
so I'm interested to see
where they go with that.
Outside of this class,
I'm pretty much focused
mostly on my four-year-old
kid and relearning
what fun is, actually,
through her eyes.
I'd like to just see a lot
more different kinds of games
about a whole bunch
of different things.
Right now I feel we're
right at the cusp off
like a Cambrian explosion
of different ideas.
Tools are out there.
The knowledge is getting
out there-- with this idea
that anyone can make a game.
But I feel that
there are still a lot
of social and systemic barriers
to prevent people from getting
every idea into distribution.
So we're still
constrained to a small set
of genres-- familiar genres.
We see a lot of those games.
I'd like to get a greater
variety out there.